and you look back now with what you know
now and all the athletes you've worked
with at the UFC P I do you think you
would have done anything different just
for eight rounds why would you spar
around there's no air out - are you
literally just getting slower Forrest
you already slow I don't know it's again
being a pioneer like you were there
wasn't really a whole lot of guys before
you that were operating I had the other
pioneers like the Randy's and the chums
and that's what they were doing so I
better be top of it or do it they -
that's the craziest thing about you man
I gotta question them boxing it already
figured out you shouldn't beat the fuck
out of each other every day
they'd already kind of figured that no
and the other thing they figured out is
we would work with people out you'd spar
with Wanderlei Chuck Randi in boxing
they don't spar with people they're
equals past a certain point in campion
think about you know a lot of it they
start like his Floyd Mayweather sparring
with I don't know really good people his
level no no definitely not he sees
finally blood boxers and he's tooling
them yes
yeah Inc have you heard of them though
they're not famous and rich so they're
not they're not elite whereas do you
think about like a gym like our gym like
I'll just use Randy's because I don't
want to talk bad about anybody you're
fighting other champions everyday right
maybe dangerous is fuck yeah maybe I'm
thrilled together sure learn from each
other roll wrestle like control your
training especially guys that are in the
same weight class as you that may
someday fight you that's awkward yeah
yeah and there was no guidebook yeah you
know you know guys like Keith Jardine
and Rashad Evans figured out they're
like we already had to fight each other
we'll train together now so we won't
have to do it again right good move if
it works out the the level of guys now
is it's so extraordinary to see like
when you see the elite champions of
today you you just have this insane
level of a fighter it's it's really as a
person who's been involved in the sport
as long as I have I still never cease to
be
amazed at the level of town of these
guys coming up because some of these
guys coming up that you just could do
everything and they could do everything
at such a high level and you realizing
you're seeing the results of kids that
started out learning MMA when you in
five seconds oh yeah man you know I had
a purse I have a personal gym and I
remember Ronda Rousey were like now
she's gonna change my bottom line all of
a sudden I got a mat full of young women
just trading Thank You rod yeah chief
for sure changed it gina carano changed
it a little bit before her you know
people have this idea like oh you could
be pretty and fuck people up like oh
that's a totally different kind of girl
that's like a superhero like a real-life
superhero now she plays in movies right
yeah